[Musique]
bonsoir à toutes et tous et bienvenue
sur tv 78 en direct de lamhiriz de
trappes pour assister à cette 19ème
édition du cycle mythe le championnat
intercollèges de match d'improvisation
théâtrale une création de la compagnie
déclic théâtre compagnie qui est situé
vous le savez attrape maintenant comme
toutes les années eh bien nous nous
retrouvons ici dans une salle de saint
quentin en yvelines pour voir des
collégiennes et le collégien de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines échanger se
rencontrer dans des joutes verbales et
vous allez voir encore cette année c'est
un bon cru et je ne suis pas tout seul
pour commenter cette soirée puisque je
suis accompagné de ma spécialiste du
soir caroline marc soir caroline en
sarre
alors caroline c'est vous qui allez
décortiquée analysée et tentez vous
expliquer un peu tout ce qui se passe ce
soir en direct de la mairie exactement
c'est mon travail pour ce soir c'est
cool alors public d'improvisation cl
il a déjà sorti sa droite ça me touche
et tous ensemble ou tous plus haut
comment
[Musique]
un public d'approbation scène un public
qui réagit cachottier bouillant qui est
prêt à chanter qui est prêt dans ces
bons attention on va vous de chauffer sa
peine
[Musique]
oh
haye a travaillé de leur vie en salle à
maurice à toi
[Musique]
voilà vous le voyez ton caroline
l'ambiance est au rendez vous avec olive
et ses noyaux pour la retransmission
directe de ces demi finales et finales
du cycle mixte 6 9e édition déjà fait 19
vous avez participé à des sites mise
d'ailleurs vous je pense en caroline
et bien non entamés en tant que joueuse
j'ai moi j'ai commencé avec luc théâtre
en tant que benjamine habitants
directement dans la compagnie d'accord
que ça vous fait d'être utile de voir
tous ces jeunes là souvent improvisés
dans quelques instants
j'adore j'adore les voir comme ça moi g
j'ai aussi je suis aussi professeur
d'improvisation intervenante avec mes
cliques et apte et
et j'ai suivi des enfants pendant toute
l'année et même si l'on va était plus
dans cette finale etc
c'est pas trop d'ailleurs voilà et
je suis très contente et les voir quand
ils sont sur scène et twizy c'est le
moment ils sont les plus heureux et on
voit des choses incroyables tant sur les
scènes de de la mairie alors que tu
problème technique mais ça marche vous
ramène les maîtres de cérémonie la
maîtresse de cérémonie de ce soir qui
fait son entrée à faire ce lieu mythique
de la scène culturelle attrape ce lieu
qui a vu passer tellement de grands noms
de la culture comme par exemple
récemment on n'y a vu lui dire sur cette
scène on a vu matmata et il ya longtemps
si on remonte dans nos grands souvenirs
sur cette scène il y avait un gala de
danse il y a vingt ans où je me
produisais dans mon costume d'abeille et
pour ça la merise ou c'est quelque chose
c'est nos souvenirs à nous trappistes
hewitt rattrape il fleurit trappe ville
jumelée avec castiglione del lago ou
encore coprim nietzsche ou alors kong
layton mais surtout trappe capital de
l'improvisation théâtrale et ça c'est
quelque chose mesdames et messieurs
juste pour ça on peut applaudir bien
fort invitation à traves comme c'est
comme ce que seraient les bêtises à
cambrai ou alors le nougat à montélimar
c'est une vraie spécialité locale et
dans cette patinoire il ya eu des
générations d'improvisateur des dizaines
même de génération d'improvisateur qui
ont usé leurs leur jogging réglementaire
pour vous pour vous émouvoir pour vous
faire voyager dans leur imaginaire alors
là ils sont plus que quatre équipes
ils étaient 15 au début de la saison ils
sont vingt-quatre joueurs ils ont les
chocottes
ils ont les fois le trac la trouille ils
sont verts de peur mais ils sont prêts
ils sont prêts à jouer pour vous et à
vous faire voyager je vous prierais
d'accueillir pour l'échauffement
réglementaire les collèges de la main au
sol de coignières
ils encourent
montigny le bretonneux
voilà donc la première belle image
peut-être de cette soirée caroline avec
l'entrée dans la patinoire de tous les
joueurs des quatre collèges qui ont été
cités donc par amel durée gagarine de
trappes la barre au sol de coignières la
journée en cours et les prés de montigny
le bretonneux
alors à quoi il sert cet instant là
leurs enfants car oui en fait là c'est
l'échauffement réglementaire des joueurs
c'est un moment très important parce
qu'ils sont tous dans la patinoire ils
sont pas leurs maillots encore qui les
différencie selon leur collège
là ils sont tous ensemble comédiens en
fait en tant qu'enfants et élèves et les
joueurs il n'y a pas de différence il ya
aucune compétition
là c'est juste de l'échauffement tous
ensemble comme un échauffement
réglementaire et ça permet déjà de se
mettre dans l'ambiance est exact c'est
un peu testé un peu pudique c'est ça
voilà par exemple
bon un petit cocktail
ils voile au public comment il est ils
se rendent compte aussi parce qu'il est
très grande salle la merise ça fait ça
fait quand même un peu hautain et on
s'est arrêté comme le passé quand même
profite du coup marchons marchons
ensemble on se rend compte les pieds
quand la musique s'arrête aussi j'ai on
regarde le public
en faisant un personnage spécifiques oui
un personnage spécifique parce que bon
c'est un cocktail où on les voit ils
sont un peu tous un peu distingué avec
leur coupe de champagne à la il
ils boivent pas de cadeau voilà mais moi
comme vous le disais un enfant ça permet
déjà de se mettre en jeu que commencer
voilà comme un échauffement en fait j'ai
sportif de cette folle ambiance pop
music
c'est déjà fini ouais alors que
normalement un échauffement
réglementaire que ça dure cinq minutes
avec développement commun et
et qui paie pas acquis mais la bonne
question d'organisation je suppose
on a préféré faire uniquement les
chemins en commun ou la vue ils sont
chauds bouillants et j'espère que vous
voulez avec le meur mais avant de les
voir improvisé on va un petit peu changé
l'ambiance puisque nous allons
maintenant accueillir un personnage
essentiel au bon déroulement de ces
finales il sera garant des thèmes
abordés dans cette patinoire de l'esprit
qui règne
sa pugnacité n'a d'égal que son
impartialité il est capable de faire
trembler n'importe quel patinoire dans
le monde
il s'agit de l' arbitre de ce tournoi
monsieur nous règne à kiel louise
aurait bien tu
la cub
à la fin un moment important également
caroline pour voir peut-être le
personnage le plus important dans la
proviseure d'un cocktail arbitres de la
route avec les habitants oui c'est
vraiment le personnage très important
parce qu'on veut pas d'un arbitres c'est
clairement son métier pourquoi c'est un
arbitre parce que lui il va jury va il
va être toujours dans l'oeil sur le
match va donner les thèmes il mais il va
aussi siffler les fautes commises par
les joueurs
on en reparlera après et
moi hammam
image l'importance de leur faut alors
c'est un mieux son couple elle joue le
rôle du méchant voilà il joue le rôle du
méchant mais j'aurais bien qu'il fait
c'est comme inventé comme louis personne
très gentille
il est vraiment très professionnel et
surtout très important chez déclic mois
et puis l'état compagnie de mario
viens voir les comédiens
les musiciens
[Musique]
c'est le
ne portera le numéro bas
[Musique]
doit on appeler il a aussi porté le
numéro 28
moi même en 40 nm le numéro 80
[Musique]
amman avec le numéro 47
vous mettiez un
mais là même qui
l'équipe de la barre au sol de quoi
terme
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
chez par le talentueux des biens
[Musique]
le capitaine de cette équipe sur portera
ce numéro 31
laly porte le numéro de bois
nicolas bara le maillot numéro 23
là
cyril portera le numéro 15
maintenant le nuire aux nantais
enfin marie avec numéro 4
[Musique]
your engine les goûters frey demande
cette île bretonne monde applaudit s'il
vous plaît qui joue en vert sera coachée
par les lustres antoine rameaux
la capitale de cette équipe ce sera
d'autres formats tout porterait lui en
45 pour la paix
[Musique]
yaris portera le numéro 2
lala numéro 30
hidayat le numéro tous d'art à la
bureaucratie
elodie avec le terreau de 60k
on a tout d'abord équiper près d'eux
enfin la dernière équipe a tout fait et
ce poids soccer voiture en équipe et ça
j'ai fait l'équipe la judée là pour dix
jours dont les applaudit s'il vous plaît
coachés par l'ingénieux alexandra beier
[Musique]
la capitaine de l'équipe au bout portant
le numéro zéro portera le numéro 6
mondial faut 60
[Musique]
et enfin le garde
06 et qui sait nager pour les bas prix
[Musique]
avant le premier coup de sifflet une
dernière recommandation très cher public
en ce qui concerne votre participation à
la fin de chacun trop c'est vous qui
voterez allées du carton qui vous a été
distribué quelle que soit la couleur du
maillot
vous voterez avec le côté blanc pour
l'équipe à votre gauche et avec le côté
rose pour l'équipe à ma gauche donc à
votre droite
est-ce que ça va jusque là je vous ai
pas perdu super alors nous vous
demandons s'il vous plaît de voter en
votre âme et conscience en toute
impartialité évidemment pour l'impro que
vous avez préféré et non pas pour un ou
une joueuse que vous seriez venu
soutenir parce que c'est votre fils
votre bataille quelque chose comme ça en
tout cas soyez impartiale soyez fair
play votez pour l'histoire que vous
préférez monsieur l'arbitré je vous
laisse la parole le collège
youri-gagarine de kraft et les collèges
de la marée comme la croisière va
commencer c'est la première demi finale
entre la pression a certainement sur les
dépôts des joueurs et des corses
oui là c'est la pression mais ils ont
l'air vraiment très motivé c'est vrai
que capitaine nature c'est ça appelez
votre équipe c'est clair parfaite
le mieux est prête quoi
on n'était pas trop là dedans capitaine
qui est team qui était capitaine yasmine
donc c'est sa seule vous que vous
adressez à moi notre équipe c'est bien
clair amusez-vous très bonne soirée à
tous et à toutes
derrière improvisation mixte qui aura
pour thème la fureur des anges la fureur
des anges nombre de joueurs illimité
catégorie libre durée de l'improvisation
alors on va commencer car en mai avec
cette première improvisation et terme
peut-être que certains téléspectateurs
ne les connaissent pas la crise que oui
alors en fait c'est on parle d'une
improvisation mixte qu'elle savait dire
que les deux équipes vont se rencontrer
dans la patinoire un joueur de chaque
étoile
la riante actuellement ils font leur
caucus donc ça veut dire qu'ils sont en
train de créer un personnage une
activité par est un objectif pour eux
deux la personne qui rentrera dans la
patinoire
ensuite le thème la catégorie ellipses
ailleurs qu'il n'y a pas de catégories
plus tard hoover et qui rappela et enfin
y'a pas de quoi pleurer ça veut dire que
ils sont libres de choisir la catégorie
qui le veulent oui voilà fait exactement
c'est toute la différence s'ils
choisissent eux-mêmes de m catégorie pas
vous faire évidemment et puis jouera
limitée bas c'est parti c'est parti je
peux vous aider
oui le soleil alors alors l'option
soleil on l'a pas dans le contrat
initial
parce que là vous avez demandé au
contrat initial aller au paradis et
vivre éternellement donc là on peut pas
trop en faire
revenir le soleil mais je n'ai pas droit
oui bah il ya des abus vais là-bas vais
y aller c'est promis je suis concours
est toute blanche il moi je veux pas
tout blanc qu'est-ce que je peux faire
pour vous aider
bah allez voir un homme il se situe dans
l'allée georges st place 4 allez-y c'est
tout droit tout droit tout droit et vous
tournez à gauche c'est juste un bon je
vous laisse y aller bonjour vous venez
pour rossi bon c'est qu'on me l'avait
jamais faite celle-là que j'aime bien
oui c'est ouvert beaucoup
il fait chaud oui mais son bronze pas
fait pas tardé j'espère bien vous avez
plutôt devenir rouge à la limite comme
moi oui c'est trop tard en fait voilà
donc pour cette première improvisation
caroline ans est toujours difficile
peut-être rentrer dans le vif du sujet d
une faute qui a été sifflé
alors qu'est ce que c'est ce jeudi une
faute de retard de jeu en fait donc oui
c'est la première improvisation avec le
stress capitaine arthur est une crème
dès maintenant une fois une boutique de
retard de jeu pardon pour votre équipe
vous avez la joueuse luan qui rentre
dans la patinoire pour avec une
proposition très claire elle veut revoir
revenir le beau temps et la personne qui
a priori est là il se décrit comme
quelqu'un qui aurait dû pouvoir et
pourrait éventuellement faire ça et bien
prend énormément de temps pour lui dire
qu'elle ne peut pas lui rendre service
et qu'il faut qu'elle aille voir
ailleurs si il ya quelqu'un qui peut
faire ce que je veux dire donc on a
passé deux minutes à s'échanger
justement toutes ces amabilités
on aurait pu rentrer plus vite dans
l'histoire s'il avait pris un petit peu
plus quelque chose en main votre joie
nicolas merci capter toi
voilà c'est exactement une faute au
regard de jeu en fait quand la prod et
un premier temps a commencé qu'il ya
beaucoup de blabla et peu d'actions
quand on y est on va faire va faire que
les ressorts de l'histoire c'est un bon
c'est pas mal ça n'avançait pas
[Musique]
enfin je vois rien donc c'est pas la
peine de vous exciter alors et plus
principe de l'improvisation du match
d'improvisation théâtrale en tout cas
c'est le vote
voilà donc c'est lui qui décide qui a
produit peut-être le meilleur joue la
meilleure proposition que je serai là
c'est ça c'est la participation du monde
te faire importante
ils vont ils doivent voter comme on a
dit juste d'avoir en leur âme et
conscience pour l'improvisation qu'ils
ont préféré pour l'équipe qu'ils ont
préféré dans l'ensemble dans la
globalité de l'impro à la rose ou blanc
selon l'équipe
[Musique]
premier point et l'ouverture du score si
on était au foot à bord des terrains de
gagarine qui jouent en bleu donc ça fait
1 3 0
voilà c'est ça
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors on a bien vu car au niqab des
personnages ce qui est assez marqué un
prêt fort e
c'est aussi une force de l'impro savoir
aussi incarner des personnages c'est
hyper important de pas seulement jouer
des situations mais d'incarner un
personnage parce que saddam
organisations improvisation
improvisation mixte qu rapporte m à la
recherche du bataillon de saumur à la
recherche du bataillon de saumur
nombreux joueurs est limité
catégorie à la manière des romans ou des
films de cape et d'épée durée de cette
improvisation deux minutes
c'est une première catégorie carabine
qui d'imposer par l'arbitré c'est
l'attaqué de rue cap et d'épée
c'est ça la cat power cape et d'épée
alors
c'est comme elle le dit on imagine des
chevaliers ed les mousquetaires surtout
des mousquetaires des bagarres des
royaumes à sauver
l'angleterre c'est tout un truc autour
des stades voilà senna maroc y aura de
cape et d épée normalement normalement
si tout va bien et a décapé des épais
bonjour bonjour je viens côté le vin de
samui
moi je cherche sa bataille mon combat en
fait j'ai envie de profiter en votre
label nous irons ensemble nous
chercherons ensemble à longvic a aussi
bien chez valve vous avez un chemin
enfin la catégorie la
regardez ici la bataille du sang partout
au moins précieux nul à lens
de mauvais payeurs ne vous m'appelez pas
je cherche contre eux et moi je cherche
l'abattage mais moi je veux finir mon
combat
les recherches mauvais endroit le pas il
est dans une coupe
est ce que vous auriez vu une coupe
n'est pas doré argenté samedi que vous
venez ça me dire ou es ce que vous avez
fait une coupe
je pense à eux il nous avait dit pendant
qu'on devait seul le gagnant gagne et
coupe le gagnant gagne et gagnent et
combattre il faut gagner cette coupe
confiance en toi
encore une faute qui a été sifflé par
l'arbitré groupe eurasia keane
alors qu'est ce que c'est ce geste alors
je ne suis pas sûr de ce qu'est ce geste
directement g1 trouvez moi mais on va
savoir hypo d'écouté j'ai l'impression
qu'on va être trouvée très souvent dans
cette partie s'il vous plaît faites
attention à bien établir les choses
établissez les choses pour pouvoir
raconter quelque chose de pair pour le
public
est ce qu'on cherche une bataille est ce
qu'on cherche du bon vin d'accord mais
surtout pour qui fait-on mettez tous les
éléments nécessaires à une histoire pour
pouvoir construire ensemble
d'accord c'est pas parce qu'il ya des
éléments qui pourrait nous faire penser
que vous êtes dans la catégorie que tout
le monde est content d'accord la
catégorie une chose l'histoire en est
une autre merci de mettre tous les
éléments pour que le plaisir tout ce
qu'on vous demande me fait pas c'était
de comprends pas ce que je dis que c'est
l'arbitré
un peu de confusion qui avait dans des
foires aux armes que c'est la faute de
confusion tout à fait voilà bah c'est
parce qu'il n'y a pas d'histoire peuvent
être histoire et une bataille qui est
très drôle ça fonctionne très bien et se
sont pas mis d'accord dès le début juin
l'acquis chercher quelque chose et
l'autre autre chose s'ils sont pas
rencontrés sur sur le début de
l'improvisation finale
et c'est l'égalisation donc un partout
entre la marolle sol et youri gagarine
c'est un match assez serré pour le
moment car audi entre les deux équipes
oui voilà les deux de l'homme de
l'égalité on verra bien ce sera plus
tard tout est possible un combat qui
aura pour thème albert et la solitude
albert et la solitude nombre de joueurs
toute l'équipe catégorie livres du ray
de l'improvisation une minute et trente
secondes alors carolis et la première
intronisation comparer l'improvisation
comparé à leur verse 2 à nice où les
deux équipes jouent ensemble
là c'est une équipe où puis une autre
équipe jouent chacun leur tour qu'il va
proposer ça c'est donc là les caucus du
buisson personnel ccd ils font leur
caucus de leur côté ils se font dire il
a plu prévoit leur histoire et puis on
va voir les deux histoires je suis ton
pas les comparer pour pouvoir voter
comme il se doit en revanche toute
l'équipe dont je me semble-t-il douteux
des kits lucky par s'imposer
et moi ils sont à la bourre pour le
temps qui passe
alors attention petit bleu pour les
bleus ou
capitaine arthur vous prenez vous
laisser on prend preneur place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
allez
quelqu'un doit pas perdre quelqu'un avec
un black-out a perdu ligue 1 aussi
si super son corps albert là il va
encore faire une balade tout seul
abandonne encore c'est pourtant c'est
lui le seul professionnel de la nature
c'est encore albert il est encore parti
faire une randonnée
alors que ses seuls professionnels tu
voyais 26% camp adverse et celle qui
s'est la randonnée et et voyez bien
parti tout seul
la fondation albert ses leçons
c'est le seul pays vers celle ci au sol
et c'est vraiment une chance arrive que
nous les matchs en séries que nous et la
bonne chose dessus ou quoi j'ai une
grande chance tarifs que nous regardons
appel à moi je vais pas chercher loin
pour moi j'ai un doute
oui bouton fortune chez vous map la
dernière par l'équipe et rouge pendant
que les bleus s'installe
[Musique]
c'est quoi ta plainte répondent chaque
juge gazeaux
oui bon ok les invitations du tout les
cas toi bon sas ont torpillé tout seul
il peut venir vous êtes aujourd'hui
c'est parfait mais je lui ai dit hier
sans faire exprès mais quel boulet était
passé c'est avec lui
[Musique]
avec moi et moi sur ma joue suis sûr que
là tu vas nous les noms restent avec
nous anniversaire encore une fois une
faute a été sifflée contre l'équipe de
la mare au sol catégorique également que
la mare au centre de lausanne bat wil
importe vabre oui alors ça a été une
fois qu'il est rentré un peu trop tard
ap bon choix parce que vous devez avoir
toute l'équipe de présente dans
l'improvisation votre effets de mise en
scène était très intéressant mais votre
joueur n'attend était déjà dans la
patinoire pendant en réserve
il attendait son tour mais néanmoins il
recevait des instructions du coach
lilian d'accord s'il avait gardé sur le
banc
[Applaudissements]
m
les îles et les i
bien règlement très précis ok il ya un
règlement très précis à ce spectacle et
vous ne le connaissez pas il n'y a que
moi qui le connais je suis bon
[Applaudissements]
c'est oui voilà wagon karoubi n'avaient
pas on avait payé toutes les
informations parce qu'on ne l'avait pas
vu c'est sûr que c'est un coach n'a pas
du tout le droit de parler à ses joueurs
dont trois qui sont rentrés dans la
patinoire mais c'est pas son rôle c'est
ressorti à 40 régime
[Musique]
et
et le deuxième point qui est inscrit par
l'équipe de la mare aux songes ça fait
donc 2 à 1 pour l'équipe de la mare aux
songes à 1 après avoir été mené 1 à 0
voilà qui revient d'abord aux sports qui
maintenant ils prennent l'avantagé
exactement
c'est ça la prendre
jamais toutefois son rehaussement sait
pas ne pas savoir
mais je crois de gagarine n'a pas dit
son dernier mot certaine improvisation
mixte aura pour thème la légende du
gange
la légende du gange nombre de joueurs
est limité
catégorie libre durée de cette
improvisation deux minutes et 45 on va
peut-être un petit peu voyager car il
comporte promise à sion la légende du
gange
alors est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer nous rappelez vous me l'avez
dit tout à l'heure un petit peu ce qui
se passe concrètement dans les cockpits
allaient petit moment qu'on est en train
de voir où le coach est en train de
parler avec ses joueurs c'est ça alors
en fait un caucus et ses vingt secondes
parce qu'on nous le coach coach ses
joueurs alors leur donner toutes les
informations nécessaires pour avoir une
bonne reproduction qui sont âgés de 7 à
l'heure nous ce qu'on apprend à vous
êtes un personnage une action n'est pas
aidé par un objectif est l'objectif
hibbert important parce que sans
jouissance objective n'y a pas
d'histoire
quel est l'objectif d'avoir un objectif
à des gens qui mangent donc là en fait
je suis né au nom est en gros à toi donc
une fois tous les deux contre un peu ma
que sur soi qu'est ce que t'en penses
quoi
et est ce que c'est le lac tandis que la
nation en fait oui parce que des fois ça
enfle à quoi nicolas est ce que tu peux
m'aider à ramener sa fille
oui oui tout de suite jean rède mois
avant que tout parte il faut que ça les
gens ça non
à patricia y avait vérifié un siècle
occupe
oui je serai content alors je prends par
le bas tu remontes voilà et tu remontes
soit pas parfait nous l'effet
l'embrayage d'accord doit toucher des
mois gonnot d'accord jeu mais on va
continuer ouais tu voulais dire
le banquier qui plonge dans l'eau - être
un droit a pour support de tranchées qui
plongera galop dit va lui virer pour
rajeunir sa bastille mais pourrait tout
on va faire avec les frets sûr tu vois
pas aller
mais non il y va parce qu'il a bien
regardé dit d'accord magie mais à la
meinau la malédiction si on vous avait
prévenu les joueurs sont à payer
bon ben on va quand même le vaillant
oui alors encore une fois le 2 fautes me
semble-t-il côté sifflé par l'arbitré de
la rencontre alors de fautes de retard
de jeu voilà une faute de cabotinage se
déboîte béthune alors ça c'est plutôt
confusion ça certains pardon confusion
et une faute de cabotinage exactement
voilà donc confus leur aussi pour
l'équipe de s'équilibrer cabotinage à
l'équipe de youri gagarine
non on va essayer de savoir pourquoi
très cher capitaine
je suis content de pouvoir ici en demi
finale 1 on est vraiment ravi mais le
public a payé cette fois ci c'est pas
comme au collège c'est l'état qui paye
voyez ce que je veux dire
hier que la vision met la main à la
poche parce que j'ai des oreilles des
rames et cheveux mais j'entends tout ce
que vous dites d'accord
même les insolences on n'a pas le même
maillot mais on n'a même pas si vous
connaissez
on n'a pas le même maillot les bains
copains donc je reprends on aimerait ici
dans cette patinoire que les choses
soient plus claires et kasaï de l'avant
avec beaucoup plus de plus de clarté
d'accord afin que le public s'y retrouve
au-delà de l'aspect financier mais qu'il
s'y retrouve dans les histoires que vous
leur proposez d'accord donc on va vous
demander de tête rentrée - encore
peut-être de faire deux interventions
qui sont beaucoup plus lisible beaucoup
plus clair je m'adresse aux joueurs en
attend et quant à la prod2 cabotinage
c'est bien beau de vouloir rentrer et
absolument être amusant mais ça c'est
dans un second temps avant il pourra
compter quelque chose une fois que
devrait rapporter quelque chose vous
pourrez être amusant autant que vous
voudrez mais ah bon on raconte quelque
chose s'il vous plaît quant à la
deuxième faute de cabotinage pour votre
joueur il l'a très bien compris je ne
reviens pas dessus elle est valable
merci linkedin année là il me semble un
en ayant rendu les restes de
l'improvisation que si on a tous fautes
personnelles
on est exclu directement au fait deux
fautes personnelles et c'est l'exclusion
du match
mais oui en fait le cabotinage c'est une
faute importante parce que pourquoi pas
10 parce que quand quand un joueur
rentre dans la patinoire
juste pour faire une blague là l'impro
n'avance pas et comme là on a vu en fait
l'histoire n'avance pas
alors là vous l'avez vu en fait on a
coûté les cartons parce que le score est
serré les cartons alors heureusement
qu'on a des supers à score vite elle dit
et marion et j'ai quand même le
troisième point pour le collège de la
barousse d'adekar et creuser d'apprendre
à apprendre à prendre son envol
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
improvisation combat qui aura pour thème
une bougie dans la nuit nombre de
joueurs arrivent vite et catégorie botte
secrète durée de cette improvisation 3
alors là cette catégorie votre secret
puisque ces trois catégories
car audio alors tout au long des années
on a travaillé avec les élèves une botte
secrète et c'est l'équipe et le coach
qui choisit eux-mêmes qu'est ce que sera
cette qu'est ce que sera cette fois
puisque cette phrase cette botte secrète
et hop voilà et est donc à plein temps
parfait cas d'accord elle n'a porté à
maudire j'expire continue et c'est à la
manière d'un moteur particulier quand
même
capitaine arthur été blessés on laisse
très bien en place allez allez capitaine
yasmine est souple annoncé le terreau
sur lequel vous décidé d'informer les
gens s'intéressent à georges feydeau
et
quant à la force bonjour désolé de venir
au sida bah oui hier donc cette liste
pourra sans s'essouffler j'ai bien sûr à
vis encore cet autre api quatre ans
kenny romaine des fier je vais la
rajouter une vingtaine d'autres que j'ai
ici
tous ces efforts on est tout seul ça y
est
peur que mon mari nous voit il est pas
là ou non
mais marie elle est là je vous demande
en mariage 6/8 7-5 je rentrais monsieur
depardieu
bonjour si on marie bonjour madame mame
quelle belle journée oui vous l'avez
vous remercie en fait elle vous trouve
avec le fleuriste du carton jour
monsieur
c'est bien beau bourg
[Musique]
j'ai fait en faire des fleurs c'est un
très vieil ami et plus c'est un vieil
ami que tu te rends même des fleurs
keira me déplaît je te préviens je te
prends le ba ba monsieur ça fait quand
même quatre fois alors pour ces 4 arrive
[Musique]
hélas en haut lieu c'est parce que vous
pensez et qui t'aime je sais qu'ils les
tuent je suis moins fort prix
[Applaudissements]
oui georges feydeau les histoires de
paca on s'est trop tardé pas à ce
qu'elle la balance où il est dans le
placard se pratiquer pratiquer ce qu'on
pouvait annoncer au public l'auteur sur
lequel vous décidez d'en profiter
william shakespeare
[Applaudissements]
c'est pour shakespeare que pour appeler
à la pâte c'est bien super nous allons
enfin pouvoir lui notre revanche a sonné
en antidote me brûler sa bougie en clair
le roi le roi ce méchant le l'homme le
plus cruel au monde
je veux la princesse petit serviteur
robe vous avez bien en miroir toile
magnifique roy tous deux les fleurs tu
attends de voir le rayon je sais je sais
je vais bien j'ai compris j'ai fait
apportez moi
richard notre dame il attrape ce ballon
mais comme cette plaie qu'est ce que
vous faisiez l'argent du roi aller lui
chercher une hache tout juste nous y
aller est ce que vous voulez tuer le roi
[Musique]
pour dames et du poison dans sa soute à
voiles pour vous prouver malgré du
cuivre j'ai besoin
cette bougie
je suis là c'est un miraculé soient
attendus venus nous rejoindre ils
capturent 2006 qui paraissent à tous
samedi matin ma douce alchimie titre
accor détient pourrez mixer qu'il sait
que c'est parti
et à partir de maintenant je suis le au
revoir merci voilà à la manière de
shakespeare dont il ya des rois tumeur
mais il ya aussi ces packs e ttc
beaucoup de comédies à shakespeare va
sortir saba ils ont quand même brûlé le
roi ils ont brûlé le roi la reine a été
truqueuse et se sont tous marre et
pillent juin bab
j'avais vu des choses dans cette
improvisation
néanmois fait attention à mieux vous
partager la parole et ne pas laissez
vous emporter ne pas vous laisser
emporter par ses élans de parole un peu
comme ça voyez ça va trop vite qu à un
moment donné on on est les uns sur les
autres
si vous voulez que le public en profite
pleinement que william shakespeare qui
se retourne dans sa tombe
en fait souvent quand on est en jeu
parfois et surtout
quand ça se passe bien on prend on est
dans l'excitation et on oublie c'est
quoi la catégorie quoi on parle
c'est propre d'un peu de rudesse voilà
torride est ok mais on oublie qu'elle
est le vocable adapté normalement à la
catégorie
et c'est encore un point qui est inscrit
par le collège de la mare au sol ça fait
quatre ans
[Musique]
score s'alourdit heures car on dit chez
vous annonce que ce match et remporté
par l'équipe des rouges
mon père savait
donc pour avoir des chutes de la mare e
sole ceux qui remportent la rencontre
cette première de mm
ni que l'équipe des roses à prendre
place écrite et rouge
l'équipe et faire un bon plat sous les
pieds c'est plus pour la deuxième demi
finale
et oui sous vos yeux les collèges de la
jury des prêts se met en place pour la
deuxième demi finale
[Musique]
voilà donc caroline cette deuxième demi
finale entre le collège de la jeu
d'elancourt et le collège des prés de
montils bretonneux pour qui c'est la
première participation dans dans ce
cycle d'un sont entrés cette année donc
dans les deux collèges
donc c'est une
rend très belle rentrée quoi c'est une
belle rencontre pour le collège les
frais alors que collège delajoux était
déjà mal l'année dernière les recettes
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
capitale où vous seul vous que vous avez
ça - dans votre équipe c'est bien clair
ni très bien les verts tenaient prêtes
capitaine para sa seule vous que vous
êtes à moins de votre équipe c'est bien
oui capitaine para seul vous que vous
avez récemment nous votre équipe c'est
bien clair oui merci quelques pépins
tension à abu coach pourrait coûter des
points votre équipe bon match à tous
improvisation improvisation mixte qui
aura pour thème les espoirs de dame
nature
les essais
les espoirs de dame nature nombre de
joueurs inuits et catégorie libre a duré
de l'improvisation 3 me trois minutes
séparément gabonisation finalement oui
parce qu'il faut prendre le temps pour
pas je vais tenir ses forces dans la
dernière minute ont consommé l'histoire
si salma est vraiment 1,3010 le voir
c'est la plus longue improvisation
sommeil depuis
petite information aux carrures parce
que qui a gagné l'année dernière c'est
bondé et l'année d'avant
si le collège eisen d'humanité l'année
d'abord le collège le village
et puis juste avant s'étaient aussi
cours des jours qui va gagner cette
année
elle est du bon moi je les connais cet
apôtre il a dit ma mère m'a appelé parce
que vous êtes et passe coup du père
avoir relooké
[Applaudissements]
ça veut pas à commencer par les ba ba
j'avoue palais des bleus mais parce
qu'en fait le pen du violet du range des
beti du jaune du rock
là j'ai trouvé cette version des faits
oui bah maman on change tout cas plus on
prend tu devais être des choses oui même
si c'est plus naturel qu'une once moi
c'est on a payé pour un relooking
je suis pas venu pour côté des boutons
maintenant comprendre le jaune et le
violet d'accord pompiers de celle d'agde
à l'aube est moche c'est ça mais moi je
suis là mais moche c'est pas ben brik
son copain l'iphone pas mené on le met
sous le nez ou les mecalac je viens du
nil là ça fait ensuite allé chercher et
je peux me mettre au pot les coûts m ah
oui oui c'est ça me choque c'est
nécessaire pour ma famille on va plus de
shabbat et berne
maintenant les affiches les habits à
délimiter les élites égérie je pouvais
plus comme on dit c'est parti trop loin
là j'ai dit avant je vais parce que j'ai
[Musique]
c'est la nouvelle collecte la mère
nature la nouvelle collection d'art
nature son corps scène qui savent avec
la terre violet jaune maintenant dans le
18 mai chez super sexy comme ça ça donne
mais ok c'est comme ça qu'ils
apprendront relève aller au québec salue
et je vois le m il faut les mettre en
place et n'avait pas jeûné par des
pollutions blanche j'ai pas tout compris
la carotte jamais capté quelques heures
il me sens en fait je me rappelle de ce
site et rudesse excessive en feng
finalement on a eu beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup de relève dans cette rencontre
se dit à chaque fois
attends mon idée mon idée mon nez
on n'a personne n'achète h et son caucus
alors qu'en fait ils rencontrent leur
maman il faut accepter l'autre et peut
être mélangé des copies on va écouter
demander l'expulsion
je suis mauvais d'accord bien loin de
moi cette idée très cher capitaine
écouté bien parce qu'à partir de
maintenant nous ne reproduisez vous ne
reproduirait plus les mêmes veut d'abord
une faute de procédure
c'était annoncé 1 vous êtes une équipe
très mal composé vous avez quatre filles
une fille entre première faute de
procédure
une deuxième faute de procédure il vous
manque un garçon
c'est idiot mais c'est parler mon
féminisme
ici il s'agit de parité
sa mise en jeu en sueur d'ailleurs là
c'est plus mon masculinisme qui parle
parce que c'est les garçons qui me
retient l'attention
quant à la photo s'il vous plaît de
rudesse excessive pour votre équipe vous
avez votre joueur du cac qui laisse
place à la joueuse de l'équipe d'en face
pour prendre la parole et pour expliquer
un petit peu ce qu'elle bien amenée dans
la patinoire et il rentre dans
l'improvisation en faisant un contrecoup
complet de ce qu'ils attrapent se
raconter elle expose calé dame nature
que c'est la pollution que dalle à des
problèmes à régler et lui il propose un
relooking
alors pourquoi pas mais en tout cas la
métaphore n'était pas assez précis quant
à la faute de confusion pour les deux
équipes
vous êtes un petit peu trop bouge en
hurlant et vous cherchez trop à vous
imposer les uns les autres
écoutez vous jouer ensemble et vous
verrez clavier sera beaucoup plus belle
pour tout le monde merci c'est peut-être
la leçon dame nature
écoutez vous la vie sera c'est tout est
fait pour vous alors alors on va
récapituler les fautes voix sur les
pauvres parce que on fait tous des
erreurs
[Musique]
ça ça là comme ça comme ça te prend se
faire dédicacer chloé égal comme ça
comme ça ça vaut d'être sacrés si vous
attend est là et la confusion on a eu
tous à la corde en nappes aux accents
peut dire que ça va mal commencé puisque
il essaie peut-être de trop s'imposer
pour essayer de marquer le point
ouais mais le stress parfois ça va faire
des choses
ils vont se poser mon se calmer vont
prendre le temps et ça va alors là les
centres est compté
donc ça veut dire que le point et c'est
assez serré sa 6è
puis comme la mairie si grande que ça
finalement ya beaucoup de cartons a
compté alors pendant qu'ils sont en
train de compter car lui parce que on
appelle temps de le dire mais vous avez
également participé vous avec deux
équipes que vous avez suivi tout au long
de l'année c'est ça oui on avait fait
participer
au championnat donc moi je les ai suivis
depuis octobre
[Musique]
des équipes qui sont le collège
champollion avant impôts devrait jamais
en france
ok sur bois d'aller jusqu'aux phases de
qualification donc c'est le premier
point pour le collège de la jo ça fait 1
à 0 et pour terminer donc caroline à la
hauteur de titres ne sont pas là
malheureusement ce soir dans la
compétition était compliqué c'est ça on
allait il ya beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de niveaux de plus en plus c'est ces
dernières années de plus ces deux
équipes qui sont rentrés cette année que
vous aviez alors sauf une peut-être ils
n'ont les deux je les avais déjà réservé
et enfin c'est pas moi qui les avais
mais on tourne en tant que co mais
c'était déjà fait noyau qui vont vous en
direct ainsi nouvelles provisions mixte
qui aura pour thème trahison shampoing
et mise en plis catégorie libre durée de
l'improvisation deux minutes
alors pensez des thèmes comme ça un peu
un peu loufoque
qu'est ce que vous pensez qu'ils se dit
là dans le caucus à leurs trahisons
shampoing émis des mises en plis alors
comment on fait une histoire avec ça a
fait en essais de paul le mot qui va le
plus donné l'histoire où elle est déjà
le mot trahison
on imagine des problèmes des histoires
un peu un peu si je peux dire et après
shampoing exemple ça peut se passer dans
un salon coiffure par exemple par
exemple marquant une histoire est habile
cette injection de coûts qui s'accroît
pas c'est quoi cet argent rendez-vous
attaque
[Rires]
résultat 3 me après c'est pas possible
dépêchez-vous il m'attend bc oui matin
par quatre cartons haut du mont des cats
on voit bien quand ça
elle et moi vous laisser on parle trop
tôt elle fera ma vie ma tante coupé
dépêche-toi des quelque chose vous avez
créé bana est ce que vous les jeux on
s'éduque fraîcheur apporté quoi mais il
est beau et moi je suis vous le dira
bien fort douteuse et qui complète alors
caroline oui
qu'est ce qu'on peut dire si cette
improvisation est ce que l'objectif a
été rempli sk une histoire qui a été
rapporté parce qu'au fond elle
moi je n'ose pas tant que ça me met
l'accent feront alors comme vous savez
capitaine para dans le match
d'improvisation on est censé tout
inventé tout créé en tout cas ne pas
faire la promotion d'une marque d'une
autre
vous avez cité un papier bien connu que
vous avez certainement de votre cartable
merci de me sortir ah ça c'est la faute
de clichés un peu de plus chez qui nous
sont récurrentes dans les majeures
prises à sion par ma voix de ceux des
bobards choses connues on l'appelle
aussi la peau de déjà
et du coup d'oeil sont toujours un vent
qu'il soit bien inventer des marques
jean marc nantais marque
dans le mot qui souffre encore excisées
et c'est un deuxième point justement
caroline qui est un free pas par
l'équipe de l'avion d'elancourt parce
qu'ils ont compris la leçon et que
maintenant dans leur confiance et du
bien se tenir
rallié à huis clos s'est pas trop
improvisation combats y aura pour thème
ça marche à la vapeur ça marche à la
vapeur nombreux le joueur illimité
catégorie à la manière des films de
charlie chaplin durée de cette
improvisation unités 15 secondes à une
minute et quinze secondes ça va être
assez rapide et la catégorie c charlie
chaplin
qu'est ce qu'on va voir elles font le
bret pour ce qu'on aimerait voir céder
un promu est sans parole et sans bruit
non pas le royaume a tenté mais surtout
des avec un petit accompagnement musical
exactement typique qui donne le tempo
voilà ddd finit jamais et comme on a un
super groupe avec nous ce soir
bah ça va être un super moment
non seulement merci côté vert pour le
capitaine pas vous prenez vous laisser
beaucoup c'est très bien placé quel
courage
[Musique]
amisco je vous laisse marseillais
quelques notes de musique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
m
à
[Musique]
on
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
metella 2 cl vous fait d'étincelles
[Musique]
et
alors c'est très compliqué ce qu'il faut
raconter une histoire piste avec les
limites les gestes les émotions
peut-être que se traduit sur le village
s'est passé pas évident
c'est un très bel exercice que c'est
beaucoup d'image pour le public c'est
toujours
chouette de voir ça on trouve en général
les avancées c'est tout
des tableaux pour voix et avec la
musique
il n'aurait pas fait
ça marche toujours à peu près jeu
et puis là encore le public a pas réussi
à départager toute improvisation et du
coup c'est encore un décor
alors on se disait tout à l'heure à
caroline les deux un prix cassé de bonne
qualité parfois du mal à savoir
main justement vous disais tout à
l'heure l'année dernière le palmarès et
bien c'était le cas la suisse aurait
donc il a emporté le deuxième c'était le
collège alexandre dumas de maurepas les
3e de collège albert einstein de magny
les hameaux et le quatrième s'est elle
ajoute on qui est en train de jouer
actuellement contre le collège des prés
donc on voit quand même quelques petites
expériences qui a été acquis par par le
colosse de la joue sur ses seins
l'année passée c'est une équipe où l'on
retrouve depuis depuis plusieurs années
déjà
[Musique]
on les voit évoluer plus que si certains
son avis la 6e à la 3e
dans l'es4 on doit pas près de faire
leurs premiers pas merci
pour les verts 149 sont les roses 90 et
deux premiers points inscrits dans cette
rencontre pour l'équipe des prêts de
monty vêtements de l'eau dont le sport
qui est réduit doussain toujours entre
rappeurs collège
potter c'est mérité
proposer des réponses pour a
on leur a plaidé
chouette ait lieu
plus sur la patinoire du choral parfois
c'est ça plus aucune
un négationniste lui rapporte m un
vautour aux alentours vont nous jouer
activité catégorie mois durée les veines
l'improvisation par une question je vous
ai pas posé carmine c'est là on voit
effectivement qui est un caucus qui est
fait l'importance du coach qui va donner
des indications parce que ce sont quand
même des jeunes joueurs et qu'est ce qui
se passe quand on n'a pas d'idée il ya
un thème qui donc comme ça pour vous qui
avez fait de l'improvisation on sait pas
quoi faire
et qu'est ce qu'on fait c'est vrai on
s'est dit alors la bo alors qu'il a une
idée personne alors déjà en compte sur
les autres souvent quand on n'a pas
d'idée marais
sinon on se dit bon au moins je vais
prendre un personnage et ses mythes fait
qu'on a de la chance ni l'autre je suis
d'autres histoires j'en ai trop marre
tout le monde est heureux je veux que
tout le monde soit prêt je vais leur
jeter des sorts
tu veux faire quoi avec son jeu
du forçat fait leur envoyer des vautours
ya déjà des moutons pour moi
à dépasser on va les prendre le dessus
non j'en ai besoin
[Musique]
non non non par une capture du thon
faisait carrément pas
retourney
rouler quand tu as tué moi c'est plus
facile de dire c'était sale pour tout ça
confie tu le manges
des baisses d'impôts on le comprend
c'est pas beaucoup de mal aux gens je
crois que la vie commence à s'énerver là
alors pourquoi justement expliquez nous
pourquoi il commence à s'agacer
on a l'impression que ça casse par
rapport à ce qui est proposé en jeu oui
parce que hilton désinformation il leur
dit qu'il fait il faut qu'ils arrêtent
de vouloir prendre la place il leur dit
que y est c'est confus on n'a pas
d'histoire et continuation pas d'écouter
justesse une faute de rudesse excessive
vous avez un joueur qui rentre dans la
patinoire et qui nous explique mme à
terme qui est 100 vautour est une poule
qu'est ce qu'il vient à mener alors il
fait des bruits fait des bonds
c'est rigolo mais qu'est ce que c'est
sinon on ne sait pas on prend pas parti
de plus clair non pas venir juste pour
faire le nombre pour faire l'équilibré
par rapport aux sinon ça n'a pas de sens
dans ce conte vieux montrer au public
quant à la botte de confusion pour les
deux équipes
essayer d'être plus clair dans les
quêtes que vous mettez dans l'ombre dans
vos histoires très cher capitaine qu'est
ce qu'on raconte
où est ce qu'on va d'accord vous parlez
d'un sortilège le départ que la vôtre
qui
et puis finalement fait apparaître des
choses depuis on les empile et puis on
pense que ça finit par non c'est pas
comme ça qu'on construit s'il vous plaît
annoncé ce que vous voulez faire vous
avez un sortilège a placé aller jusqu'au
bout de la première idée c'est sûrement
la meilleure en tout cas c'est celle que
vous aurez le plus le temps de
développer merci c'est vrai ce jeudi
puisque la brigade sont bonnes c'est
juste qu'ils vont jamais au bout il les
explique pas en gros il est là il ya un
sortilège du début qu'elle voulait l'on
ait la volonté et puis on a complètement
après c'est parti
en poule vautours et aux blagues presque
du cabotinage et
ouaip et d'histoire et à plus de
sortilèges et bien le sortilège en tout
cas le sort aura basculé du côté de la
fio qui marque un troisième point et ça
fait 3 à 1 en faveur du collège mais
l'enfant la charge d'un certain âge on a
quand même l'impression qu'on est en
train de ramer lacarrau dit leila sarah
main pour raconter des histoires
[Musique]
improvisation comparer qui aura pour
thème l'amour selon elisabeth nombre de
joueurs inuits et catégorie botte
secrète durée de cette improvisation 2
minutes et 30 secondes battant la botte
secrète évidemment château type a une
botte secrète différents ou pas un mais
chaque match on verra cette botte
secrète fallon rappelle que la botte
secrète c'est une catégorie qui a été
travaillé normalement voilà travail au
long de l'année et en plus je choisis
par les élèves
les joueurs et les coachs et c'est à la
manière d'un auteur particulier
[Musique]
silence sur les bas merci
capitaine où vous prenez vous les fait
très bien kallel générosité voyons
quelle hauteur les verts nous ont
préparé le public lorsque vous décidez
james dash - qui vit dans la salle pour
ceux qui se demandent mais c'est qui ça
on est où des cris c'est pas ici
possible je sèche
perdue au top pas si longtemps se
contentant ferme et et défend un espace
pour libre avec lui pour aller voter
puisque vous êtes ici pour vous protéger
enfin je je suis ici pour vous protéger
de la guerre il n'y a aucune forte pour
sortir
vous devez vous sauver vous même
une guerre lakers langage je sais qu une
guerre higuain genre tombe pouvait
coiffer et puis on va explorer sur votre
ceinture on va me levais je sais quand
on va sortir de la pac forte c'est quoi
pour trouver une porte et un problème
[Musique]
est la comète mais j'aime beaucoup mais
c'est pas pour vous allez avant dans la
nourriture chaque jour de l'eau de la
viande et c'est tout vous devez survivre
à moi moi moi moi avec la troupe
2 james d'acheteurs célèbre romancier
américain né en 72 il est spécialisé en
sciences fiction et en fantaisie
lisez moi pardon je cherchais le
plastique multi parfaites j'avais lu
dans cette capitale l'outil open
on va annoncer au public l'auteur jean
qu'elle voulait improvisé nous allons
alors à 4 à christie
enfin si vous applaudissez parce
qu'elles vont faire d'akasaka tube parce
qu'elle a réussi à le dire
il fait chaud
ça me rappelle un examen pour entrer
dans mon école de médecine je les
réussis en suisse qui se bousculent
mademoiselle alexandra oui alors si nous
raconte bien d'autres amants est mort il
ya pas très longtemps
stigmate et vous l'avez vu caen pour la
dernière fois yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah a
notamment fait combien de temps avant sa
mort très exactement 2 heures c'était en
ville en voyons vous avez des liens
forts avec moi aussi bas c'est normal
c'est finalement oui donc si on roule
bien j'ai mené mon enquête
vous êtes disputé fortement avec votre
mari vous êtes réfugiés avec notamment
vous rappelez oui
ok inspecteurs via une goutte de sang
écoute ou whisky
[Musique]
un sale type personnes qui vont jouer
les ficelles
je confirme je proviens annoncé lui
c'est lui moi c'est moi ou c'est pas
voir confirme c'est lui notre musée de
son prêt charles amand bat lequel
patrick ou s'embarque les deux ils
étaient amis il aimait il aimait c'est
bon ça suffit
non c'est un appartement
c'est un imposteur
alors deux auteurs qui sont assez
différents
même quand nous voilà dans l'époque dans
le genre et puis on l'a vu dans les
impôts c'était des enfants de troupe
on va voir tiers convaincu public poigne
et encore une fois c'est le collège de
l'âge aux démarques cac a pris un point
donc ça va être difficile pour le
collège de prêtres les actionnaires à
partir parce qu'il fallait parfois le
public à des coupures des équipes et des
joueurs et
comment travaille un auteur car audio
sur une année là avait été à des élèves
des excès de travailler alors on était
souvent mais en fait on essaie de voir
avec eux et j'espère qu'ils connaissent
je te propose plusieurs moteurs ou
l'armement et ensuite une fois qu'on a
autant on le dit bien évidemment de lire
ses livres
si parce que parfois ça nous arrive de
ne pas avoir lu et
et ensuite on essaie de voir les beaux
le langage
dans les situations quel genre de
personnage quel prénom sont réguliers et
quoi l'armée turque l'ihh pour lancer
des soins
[Musique]
j'écoutais caroline c'est déjà l'heure
de la finale déjà sa patrie avec
l'équipe de lavenu qui vient à l'instant
et bien de marquer de remporter la
victoire
deux côtés ce sera et qui furent la mare
au sol s'est cassé avait remporté la
première demi-finale exactement entre
son demeure depuis longtemps oui c'est
ça
ça sert à ça
où
ça m'a donné un petit à petit renouveau
une nouvelle rencontre peut avoir
parfois il ya des équipes qui sauront
mieux que d'autres
maintenant c'est le gros mots manquent
nous allons commencer cette finale
[Musique]
le champion intercollèges de match
d'improvisation le sait que le collège
que la chaux
fraîcheur public
je vous souhaite une très bonne note
[Musique]
la barre légale
d'achat public fait une finale
à
[Applaudissements]
le match a commencé improvisation mixte
qui aura pour thème sujet sensible
sujet sensible nombre de joueurs un par
équipe catégorie libre durée de
l'improvisation de lui
brassard c'est ce que pour un joueur
deux minutes c'est lui c'est vraiment
une impro de finale donc c'est vraiment
très compliqué un joueur ça veut dire ça
veut dire que pendant deux minutes il va
devoir porter tout leur poids sur ses
épaules
c'est un sacré exercice parce qu'on
envoie en général le joueur ou la
joueuse qui est le plus à l'aise non
sans bon déclic est un joueur qui à
l'aise qui a confiance après évidemment
ça en mixte en question deux pour se
soutenir l'un est pas un solo c'est par
un solo c'est pas une comparer
un tout seul et la ddt est-ce que larbi
tapas et réfuté sur ce que là ça peut
permettre peut-être le contraire une
histoire à deux et ne pas avoir de
parasites pour vous peut-être
[Musique]
piatti il est mort parce qu'elle
conduisait la voiture
j'ai pas un accident
toutes mes condoléances idem en moi des
gens
aujourd'hui ils sont en cours j'ai vécu
une super terre de basket
ouah
je suis allé les paul est en fête
t'es pas que tacticien chocolat chez moi
[Musique]
tu es mon nouvel ami quelqu'un qui
m'aime me rendais dollar mois de la
bouteille d'accord
j'attends d'accord
regard sur la voiture comme en plus il
est mort
amadou
nathan
t'es pas un conseil mais ta ceinture
il ya d'abord eu aussi une belle
improvisation cueillir en contre comme
ça rend con quoi exactement
c'est je pense que brendan harris
[Musique]
et nos premiers points de cette finale
qui va à kaunas de la mare au sol de
quoi guerre grâce notamment au joueur
numéro 57 c'est nathan voilà que
beaucoup faire le guignol
oui les bienfaits que les autres oui
mais je les ai rencontrés et c'est vrai
qu'il fait beaucoup l'ignorent mais il
le fait bien visiblement parce que si
sur la patinoire il arrive à obtenir des
personnages comme ça où il arrivera
compte et l'avesnois histoire c'était
rigolo c'est chou
à l'invitation comparer tu rapportes m
you are beautiful
[Applaudissements]
m
nombre de joueurs illimité catégorie
chanter avec accompagnement musical sur
la première chanter donc 2 2d de la
soirée de la finale
alors qu'est ce cas comme élément dans
la chanter on peut on peut dire déjà que
ya la voix voilà voilà oui il faut à peu
près chanter c'est à dire que tout doit
être dit en chantant c'est pas comme
comédie musicale où on peut parler et
chanter là non on ne fait que chanter
donc ça peut amener des des situations
assez cocasses et après comme il ya
accompagnement musical
ils ont un micro professionnels havre
est une vraie un pro de finale en 20 ans
manière avec des vrais musiciens avec
des vrais de vrais musiciens et le sujet
donc you are beautiful
oui c'est parce que c'est normal allez
voir un docteur généraux
courageux qui va commencer alors
attendez bien la première boucle puis
quel est mon outil créé avant le crash
en paix
[Musique]
là
oh là
oui tous ces thèmes que toi que toi que
toi
je t'aime mon amour
alain vieux
allawi
[Musique]
don
d'où aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
oh
[Musique]
je t'aime mon amour question toujours
autant
[Musique]
mon amour je t'aime je t'aime je t'aime
je t'aime
je fais beaucoup de temps
je pense que ma main
[Musique]
ah ah
je dis que
la belle personne ment mois avant toi tu
me feras quoi
dans ce ciel
official essai
la relation
non
de quoi
attends croix
[Musique]
à
je suis là
[Musique]
oh
animaux
[Musique]
oh
tiens
g
là
et
à
chanter caroline ce quelque chose qui en
général se sont défaits à ses classes à
mais l'ambiance dans toute l'amérique
on est content j'ai quand même vu
quelques fois de sifflet mais alors
qu'est-ce que c'est plus difficile comme
ça alors respect de la catégorie ou du
tech ou du tub
selon les explications à cela je
parierais sur la catégorie très cher
capitaine une faute de non-respect de la
catégorie à l'arrivée les micros y avait
la musique mais alors pour le champ s'il
vous plaît je pense qu'il va falloir
venir autant des fois on aurait cru que
peut-être éventuellement il y avait un
truc un peu rapport mais souvent c'était
dérapant voilà tout simplement parce que
vous profitez et on me l'a très bien
signalé j'ai regardé le prime il est
beau cette mare mais parfaitement
partout mais vous savez parfaitement
taillé tout est bien il vous a vus en
train de vous donner des consignes alors
que le temps de concertation était
terminé et ça c'est interdit
ça c'est interdit c'est tout à fait un
dernier je sais pas si vous avez vu
tout à l'heure pendant le passé l'autre
équipe
ils avaient tous le doigt sur la bouche
pour éviter pas laisser cette nouvelle
technique monde mais bon ils sont quand
même parler
et ceux qui ont chanté remarquer donc 2
à 0 en faveur du collège de l'afld a
barré d'un trait manière
c'est quand même un exercice difficile
car nous n'en avons ni un micro suivre
les pas suivre la musique et puis
inventé complètement départ aux mines
puis c'est plus que l'impro
et puis devant un public possible
nîmes en c1 et lampe uv dans une énorme
salle d'un coup devient chanteur a
enchaîné juste population mixte qui aura
pour thème fin de peine sans la guerre
nombreuses voies réduites et catégorie
libre durée de cette improvisation une
petite minute
alors caroline comment on peut
improviser en une minute r appliquer une
histoire
alors j'ai dit alors en fait pour le
proviseur inouïe dans ces cas là il faut
que se passe plein de choses pour
raconter une histoire il faut qu'il se
passe quelque chose que ça peut pas être
juste eu blabla une impro deux minutes
il faut qu'on aille là là là là et que
ce soit assez cadré ou alors il faut
juste faire une image mais emilie c'est
trop lourd pour juste une image
on va voir ce que vous proposez
la belle la tiare manip la guerre c'est
mieux dans l'histoire
ap pas fait la guerre avant regarde on a
eu plein on s'entend la deuxième guerre
mondiale la guerre froide et que ça lui
donnait pas fait d'études en tête
en revanche on n'écrit pas soin de faire
la guerre alors ouais on veut la guerre
pour la galerie parce qu'il prend un
fusil d'assaut mais la cimade il vient
la retirer ou l' aquila officie beat là
et vous était donné que ça va très très
très à coeur
mais ils ont bien réussi l'exercice la
boucle a été bouclée donc il se battait
pour la paix il sort du mickey paquette
ont présenté la guerre que cette
programmation et ses affaires d'une
ampoule est aux anges
pasqua jeu
mika repensé et qualité l'intégrité de
choisir pour cette intronisation
voilà c'est le premier point qui est
marqué par l'équipe de la géo et ça fait
2 1
toujours pour la raho folle parce que
c'est le joueur phare de la géo malcolm
reviens porte des points pour l'équipe
c'est souvent comme ça qu'on les découpe
d'un pont
il ya un tour trois beaux arts ou
d'aussi beau un peu plus beaux lacs
montre souvent fait d'autres arrivent
souvent a en tout cas chez improvisation
comparer qui aura pour thème un avenir
sans avenir
au bout de ce soir il imitait catégorie
comptait durée de cette improvisation
deux minutes et quinze secondes
alors c'est la première catégorie
comptait de la soirée alors expliqué
l'autre caroline alors une catégorie
compte et c'est très simple il y à un
compteur qui va venir de chaque équipe
on avançait et qui va raconter sa liste
cette histoire un peu à la manière d'un
fonds qui se fait ou deux pour enfants
il était une fois c'est souvent comme ça
que ça se passe
et puis derrière
les importateurs
oui celle ci a raconté par notre boucle
au compteur la conteuse ça se met en
avant scène c'est plus derrière et à la
seule qui leur fut exactement et puis
quand la piteuse le condor maradi on se
tait et laisse les joueurs
normal en fait trop dans cette foule
côté rouge mollo
non
c'est normal capitaine vous pouvez vous
voulez faire
reprenons très bien en place il était
une fois sur un océan inconnu en
capitaine avec son grand navire vert en
fin journée quelque part après trois ans
de voyage pour aller nulle part
super et bien évidemment vous poser la
question mais pourquoi est-il parti est
bien pour trouver le trésor le plus
incroyable que la terre connue
monsieur monsieur s comprend trop bien
précis vous peut-être si vous arrivez à
le trouver pour le comptoir et ben
normalement ici mais bon c'est pas moi
je vais chercher il n'est pas là
monsieur venez pas ici t'es dans la
merde
loulou blum contours neige on n'a qu'un
plonger pour aller chercher par le
trésor alors comment dire qu'il ya 70%
bref le capitaine le capitaine pardon
essayez de parler correctement aux
longages en langage approprié à son mac
l'eau mais il n'y arrivait pas en fait
vous êtes un irak à valeyrac debout
la classe non sinon j'ai plongé de la
mer tout vous reprendrez map n'est pas
coutume le capitaine s'en fiche et que
son match au parc alors on décida
d'appeler un autre match le plus
intelligent firme capitaine à banon en
fait
cartes et les traînards déjà migré pour
quelque chose de très pur maintenant un
v6 leur montage sur le pont et le
matelot qui tenait la carte la déchire
ok c
morale de l'histoire c'est qu'il va
avoir un meilleur équipage que deux
imbéciles comme on le dit mais vous
prenant queiroz se met en place
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
salut les gars alors aujourd'hui entre
deux formes une nouvelle vidéo en full
story thann
alors aujourd'hui fera goûter mes
voyages voyages à sa gâteau une histoire
des ehpad de bla alors j'étais parti
certes il travaille à singapour parce
que moi il les études c'est pas trop ça
donc j'étais parti chercher un peu
partout mais sans rien oui allez voir le
ménage en est là c'est monsieur très
beau me montre à mon premier travail la
plonge le ménage fait ce travail ne me
plaisait pas mais quand j'ai vu le
salaire ou je vais rester à sabha peau
bon ben vous devez vous êtes vous
devenez de faire ma toute première
minute
bravo ouais c'est beaucoup moins que tu
rigoles là même ce n est qu à chaque
fois et ce restaurant dès demain et ce
restaurateur en parle à tous ses amis et
tous ses amis me recruta j'étais
débordée
venir
[Musique]
bien exactement
j'avais exactement merveille à ce combat
de mots nombreux neveux
non puis je me dis que trop travail tue
le travail j'étais débordée donc j'ai
décidé de rentrer à paris
dans la ville sainte
et bah tu es rentrée
l atout ménage à faire cesser tout ça
mais c'est parce que moi je fatigue et
de t'attendre pendant que tu fais tes
petits pas constatations tuer le temps
tout le temps moi tout le temps tous tes
la balance c'est la bave pas voulu faire
le ménage et moi et mon mari divorça
c'était pas possible
j'avais jamais dit tu veux pas blesser
on avait bien paris deux équipes
[Musique]
là encore caroline 2 et 2
de compter à ses différents way2many
qu'elle fera pourtant un peu contrainte
chez elle et puis l'un peu plus haut est
la honte en plus contemporaines endroits
sur les flots les coacher sur la blague
voalavo était en fait on fait un peu
entendre est enfin parce que sinon
pourquoi des explications oui les
explications à cette faute son arrivée
chez elle alors ok c'était des
explications les plus beaux de
l'histoire des matchs d'improvisation
on va passer au vote
on va égaliser hauts ses bas ah oui
puisque la cia une égalisation
la tension va monter d'un cran aux
comptes
c'est à dire que cette
improvisation étaient difficiles à
départager non
paris
[Musique]
bien
c'est lorsque ça vous rappeler le
carreau nouveau premier match devait
commencer vous me disiez tout à l'heure
à 8 ans dans la section des benjamins de
décrypter à jouer à la scène jean
baptiste clément
un peu petit comme le riz un peu plus
petit qu'à merise attrape aussi
pourrais je me rappelle très bien de mes
premiers matches et de toutes petites
échappées l'énergie à revendre à
revendre vraiment avec de tout je
m'appelle de mes copains
allez qui j'ai joué
et mes profs et aujourd'hui sur les
collègues épique au pacs mes collègues
on est tous une grande famille
finalement le sou
un déclic a très rapidement la famille
de peter tout à fait
[Musique]
j'espère que c'est clair
pour nous ça va donner cent cinquante et
un troisième point pour le connaissent
de la mare aux foules qui creuse l'écart
attention à la vente à ce qui a été pris
la poire par l'équipe de coignières
ouais ouais ouais
lassé
c'est assez on s'est dit beaucoup sur
les résultats de ce match après si d'un
coup il ya une avalanche de fautes
si tu es coupable
ça leur sujet et cible parce qu'il
faisait votre navigation trois fautes 3
une équipe pour lui si ces trois là elle
donne tout au long du match donne un
point à l'autre qui gagne perd pas de
points mais l'autre équipe en gagnant en
fait
3 2
j'ai dormi un peu ça l'idée
dans un match sans
et l ambiance blues brothers qui a
envahi la merise deux trappes
pour cette année mais dixit mythe un
problème avec pour thème le gang des
femmes à barbe
nombre de joueurs mutés catégorie libre
durée de l'improvisation deux minutes
d'écart la question qu'on se pose de
carolis est ce que vous avez déjà
rencontré des femmes à barbe organisé en
gang
une grand-mère qui inquiète la moustache
on peut parler de pardon c'est une femme
à moustache mais pas paris alors non
alors avant je connais des gangs de meuf
par trois mots ah ouais bah oui pas
besoin d'avoir de la barbe pour faire
des gants alors comment monopolisation
qui va durer 2 minutes 40 faut être là
car au niveau va falloir construire sur
les bandes des femmes à barbe mairesse
qui est ce qu'il est les joueurs sont
obligés de proposer et un gang et des
femmes à barbe d'or pour faire
l'histoire où est ce qu'on peut appeler
des tournées de justement ils ont
répondu sont une solution
ton ventre pas admis crosby gang
une femme a vu la main de la fille vous
êtes vous inquiète
ok oui ok allez chez casino devaient se
rencontrer dans le corps on va attendre
violet on va connaître et à vous les
mains jacques participants pour toi elle
s'appelle selon des femmes soit dans
l'effort voilà elle devrait pas tarder
ouais la bonne blague
et bah oui voilà
un camion bienvenue à la mort comme un
nouveau charme super match et l'argent
d'abord isoler genre tard stephen des
femmes vous êtes une fille avec une
balle non non non aussi les cheveux
longs vous êtes sûr que ma cabane chez
le cheval mort
ça dépasse un peu d'accord bilatéral
beaucoup mais il m'en fous utilise
l'argent en fait j'aimerais retirer je
sais plus combien
mettez votre carte vieux je dors là
machinima et la tarte est bloqué c'est
rien fait j'étais sans forcément faire
tant que je priais pourquoi de cette
réplique je devrais un peu de vent
pourraient cesser la sévère expulsion je
crois la meilleure épique
c'était une très jolie un problème est
plein de trucs the void ils sont bien
entendu ce réussi à faire une oeuvre a
été respectée way est les deux mots ils
ont utilisé tous et le gang at elle
réussi à prendre l'argent et bien le
prochaine épisode tout était prêt c'est
encore un fois pour lamar odom qui est
en train de survoler cette finale 4 1
oui pour tf1 sa voix douce avec parti
lalit nikola ciric
nathan mari et je rappelle que c'est
leur première année sa profession qui
après six ans et plus tôt c'est plutôt
une bonne première année une bonne
première année
là est tout à l'heure vous êtes veille à
vtt
ddd genre de joueur dans les équipes et
en fait c'est vrai que même si boyata
toujours en jaune à certains qui sont
plus dans l'humour il y en a d'autres
qui vont être plus dans la construction
est en fait une équipe allait croiser
leurs doigts fait c'est le groupe qui
fait front
[Applaudissements]
la population un mythe mais qui rapporte
m j'aime premier sur l'échiquier nombre
de jouer avec lui tu es catégories we
meet
mais m c'est bon signe l'échiquier pas
sur l'échiquier ans c'est la débandade à
l'intérieur de la patinoire 2004
j'envoie le joueur est invité catégorie
libre curé de la profanation 3000 jeunes
premiers sur l'échiquier
alors dites nous tout au long de l'année
à caroline du coup vous allez une fois
par semaine dans les collèges combien de
temps vous restez et puis après il ya
une progression que vous essayez de deux
mètres pas ce qu'est ce que vous essayez
de travailler principalement avec les
élèves que les coûts des gens que vous
suivez
alors osons les voit une fois par
semaine une heure ou une heure et quart
ça dépend des collèges et en fait non
les prépare vraiment pour le match pour
on leur apprend vraiment les les
classiques de l'art du match
d'improvisation théâtrale on leur
apprend à se rencontrer et sur la
créance les techniques de base de leurs
obligations
je suis là pour tout le monde à en faire
manger tous les jours et un pantalon
bien joué aux échecs web sur laquelle
ils sont l'imputation oui
dassault tu peux tu as toi aussi tu veux
mais pour centre j'ai gagné six fois au
championnat du monde d'échecs que lui tu
es le meilleur baisse hier jean charles
vous avez une âme et des cd budgétaire
oui
[Musique]
ça
non
thierry noir
j'écoutais ce moment j'avais plus décalé
à trois jeux vallier je dois vous
admettre que vous déstabilisez trop tour
mondial à ce match face complètement de
l'autre côté
aie aie aie aie aie qui va vous gagnez
ce format aïe aïe aïe c'est serré je
sais je quitte l'europe aux enfants
comment un parfait un forfait
je suis mon amour des passes jeu amour
t'es pas le jeu je vous aime
relaxnews d'amour en plein après une
partie des chefs
mais ce côté autour du mot c'est parti
et troyens aulas voit différemment sur
l'échiquier même an plus tôt c'est
étrange mais je parle au nom du père au
nom du père du fils et des échiquiers
vous marion de la dame du droit
tu crois que la dame bouvet boutiques et
du rail madame de leurs prêtres dans la
salle un mariage express comme ça sur la
scène où est l'eau ya quelques mois
notre identification
mais c'est dur mais c'est du jamais vu
pire
le retournement de situation mais si
dans cette improvisation
voilà là bas n'a par exemple s'est dit
super histoire pour moi parce qu'il y
avait une écoute vraiment très présente
quand ils sont en train de échec et
qu'elle lui dit ah s'il ya eu tout de
suite il m'a dit tu sais pas quoi c'est
trop chaud et qui contient autant d'
écoute l'équipe guitare basse
et le point qui va cette fois ci à
l'équipe de la loupe
ça fais ton 4 à 2 c'est une belle
rencontre 1 1 entre les deux équipes
pour l'instant l'équipe de la maraude de
manière qu'ils gardent toujours un
avantage ça va être dur d'aller chercher
comme winnie pense que ces messieurs
favori que ça va être très dur surtout
sur une annonce la fourquet c'était la
dernière
l'impro de ce match
une fois plus
c'est parler
alors
j'aimerais qu'on fasse un tonnerre
d'applaudissements pour les faits qu est
le cas car il est pris de l'âge et
démarre au sol pour se sera vu le
spectacle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
et bien c'est le pompon c'est un moment
tant attendu
une coutume chez nous en match
d'improvisation avant de vous annoncer
et bien le vainqueur de cette grande
finale
nous avons et bien des joueurs qui ont
joué dans cette patinoire tout au long
de l'année tout au long de la saison et
ses joueurs et bien ont brillé un petit
peu plus que d'autres et ils ont été
récompensés
et oui ils ont été récompensés et avant
de remettre ces étoiles à ses joueurs de
l'année et bien nous remettrons les
étoiles de ce match les étoiles ont été
remises ce soir par une personnalité un
petit peu spéciale je dirais même deux
il s'agit de madame nelly uretères soit
je suis désolé de décor chez votre nom
et de mathieu mathieu qui est la
première étoile du tournoi de l'année on
peut les applaudir bien fort tous les
deux
ils ont remis deux troisième étoile
c'est troisième étoile attention
roulements de tambours sur vos genoux
mesdames et messieurs vite s'agit
deux images le numéro 80 qui joue un peu
le mot peuple qui revient fort
et cela ou coupe
les deuxièmes et voix
[Musique]
les deuxième étoile et oui vous l'avez
compris il y en a deux encore il s'agit
d'une joueuse qui porte un maillot de
hockey avec le numéro 75 elodie qui
jouera vert
le partage
alors tu achètes deuxième étoile à peine
paris qui joue un rouge
[Musique]
isaïe toi ils ont gagné une étoile plus
on gagne plus loin
la première étoile
celle qui vous a fait kiffer celle qui a
fait son show celle qui a brillé un peu
plus dans le ciel de l'improvisation ce
soir il s'agit d'un choix qui porte un
maillot rose
et taj est une marotte la malbaie
pall corp
voilà donc ça c'est des étoiles caroline
pour ça c'est subjectif parce que c'est
ce qu'a ressenti le père l avait chargé
de donner des valeurs authentiques sur
les majeurs de bon là c'était des genres
comme un pion au wawel où tout était
beau et bon mais son réseau était bien
donner ces étoiles procédé à la remise
de toutes nos étoiles de l'année eh bien
je vais en profiter pour accueillir des
personnalités qui nous soutiennent elle
ceci tout au long de l'année
alors j'appelle à me rejoindre dans la
patinoire pour remettre des différents
prix monsieur dominique charrier
président de la compagnie déclic théâtre
pour peu à peu dire
[Musique]
lyon
sauverait prennent en charge de la
politique de la vie complète le tir au
dessus
madame nadia a débuté déficit
[Musique]
madame hamm et l'ouvrier vice-président
de la communauté d'agglomération de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines en charge de
la culture et les vacations des
politiques publiques
[Musique]
maja plus alors j'ai fait part de sa
colère sur le 50 m libre en charge des
ressources humaines de la politique de
la ville et enfin s'il va te rejoindre
dans cette patinoire
monsieur philippe gay rum l adjoint
david de traquer les gars la culture
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
au nom de déclic théâtre je vous
remercie d'avoir pris part à ce
spectacle est d'être avec nous ce soir
c'est vraiment très important
alors il est temps de procéder à la
remise des différents trophées et on va
commencer par le trophée du fair play
qui va être remis par monsieur dominique
charrier et madame nadia haye
on va vous donner on va vous donner les
prix ce trophée est le trophée de notre
partenaire ki moon qui récompense
l'équipe qui a fait le moins de fautes
sur ses matchs tout au long de l'année
et cette année il y en a deux le niveau
et les prix sont remis au collège
alexandre dumas et au collège albert
einstein
alors si nous avons des représentants
d'établissements scolaires je vous
invite à venir de rejoindre dans la
patinoire pour récupérer ses joueurs qui
ont réalisé très peu de fautes au cours
de la saison puisque c'est 14 août pour
toute la saison pour le collège actions
du mas de morales barnston de
magny-les-hameaux hop c'est pas mal
c'est très con
or free allez-y vous avez droit de
prendre vos prix
[Musique]
et ça représente le belge albert
einstein nous avons tous aux
improvisateurs du collège alexandre
dumas on peut les saf losier je vous
remercie d'être ici et je vous invite à
bien par gagner vos places c'est
beaucoup
[Musique]
m
et messieurs dames je vous invite à
rester avec nous puisque nous allons
remettre les étoiles de l'année alors
les 3e étoile du championnat nous avons
nos assistants arbitre qui prépare est
pris il voulait remettre vous allez
remettre chacun plusieurs ses toiles à
nos joueurs
les trois de ses droits du championnat
il n y en a plusieurs cette année où ils
viennent notamment tibor du collège
certaine que j'invite à monter dans la
patinoire si l' on peut applaudir
thibault viviane à tous à l'âme du
collège courbet
il ya des attaques au lashkar gah
will de la clé essentielle
zahia d
[Musique]
oh
bon
et il nous manque une joueuse qui n'a
pas eu son prix
dans caroline quand ce sont des étoiles
sur la saison donc ce sont des joueurs
qui sont le plus distingués
donc il ya des 3e étoile des 2e globe et
la première étoile c'est le joueur qui
aura foule à jouer pour aller plus
brillé tout au long de la saison
est-ce que déjà annoncé qu'il n'était
pas à la finale le dommage non c'est
dommage et en même temps m'a tant mieux
comme ça ça pour ça c'est parce qu'on a
un jour extraordinaire n'a pas eu
d'équipé pour gueule
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
maintenant de giacometti et enfin royal
de champollion
je vous invite à vous diriger vers la
joie pour récupérer votre prix
la petite photo
[Musique]
oui
ap
et enfin mesdames et messieurs
la première étoile je vous ai un petit
peu spoilé tout aller là puisque je vous
ai parlé d'un joueur
il s'agit de mathieu du collège des sols
qui remporte un braquage
oui pour un ratio nord c'est important
car au lieu d'avoir des distinctions
comme ça personnel est-ce que ça aide à
la la la cohésion peut-être c'est fois
c'est un petit challenge en plus pour
les joueurs de cette vache joint à la
bouche en sang soir
je pense
quand on reçoit l'étoile
ça fait tellement plaisir
je sent valorisé et en même temps c'est
pas parce qu'on l'a pas qu'il faut se
croire se sentir mauvais choix ça peut
être très bon voire faire moins rêver et
ça dépend des uns est bien ce troisième
brise ce trophée de la troisième place
qui va vous est donné par notre
fabuleuse assistante arbitres marion
collet slash président de la compagnie
déclic théâtre dominique charrier alors
eh oui c'était ma petite boutade la
troisième équipe la trouve la place de
troisième revient plutôt à l'équipe qui
jouait ce soir en bleu le collège camus
voilà on peut dire que c'est les locaux
de l'étape qui remporte donc la
troisième place 2 ce site mythe 19e
édition au collège gagarine de trappes
voilà ils sont contents de leur
troisième place ça fait toujours plaisir
m
venez m'applaudir bien ce sont les
troisièmes de ce soir
il faut remettre à plat
notre championnat inter collèges je vais
appeler madame suzanne plan des lauriers
à remettre
[Musique]
alors je vous en prennent du poids c'est
d'être offerts à ces à ces dames
ils sont deuxièmes ce soir il s'agit
du collège de la chiotte lp l'équipe
pour la faune qui punit deuxième se fait
serrer en finale mais pour l'équipe 2
dames a reçu a quand même réussi à faire
la différence et c'est aussi ça
pour lâcher son deuxième match dans la
quatrième
il ya une logique l'année prochaine
c'est pour la violence
posée
là
et oui ce sont nos joyeux ce bon mais là
je vais vous demander via une ambiance
assez de plus de suspense puisque total
ont annoncé les vainqueurs de cette
foire attention roulements de tambour
rouge heureusement tués
je vais rapide et madame nous rackettent
les jours un revêtement ce premier prix
il est maman
tous
mais champions
m
le match de lyon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
un relation contenteront leur première
participation à l'inconscient et mais
c'est mérité ils peuvent être contents
ils ont commencé dans l'improvisation un
doctor donc c'est vraiment une belle
fête bateau doit être pas doublon avec
eux c'est leur première année pour la
plupart de ce qu'il veut faire
quelquefois mais on a eu des bons
moments quand même
dans la patinoire est rageant mais pour
une première année c'est vraiment super
ce super
tous les temps
ces martyrs il me semblait important de
remercier nos partenaires
alors nous en profitons pour remercier
le ministère de la culture et de la
communication le cégep commissariat
général à l'égalité des territoires
le conseil départemental des yvelines la
communauté de saint quentin en de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines la file de
droite
la médium éditions ki oon la biocoop
l'argent dans la ville
quelle fut ma tante et huit autres
partenaires tv et enfin invité fait
surtout par cette radio
ce sont les partenaires du cyclisme mais
nous tenions à remercier votre prénom
[Musique]
c'est bon pour moi de vous remercier le
remercie jamais la mer
[Musique]
merci
j'oublie à bout
[Musique]
merci à nous ceux qui font que la grande
aventure de l'abomination perdu
voilà c'est ainsi que se termine cette
soirée caroline dont je suis deuxième
championnat inter collèges de match
d'improvisation théâtrale
merci à vous d'être passés nous voir car
limité merci à vous tous merci d'organes
avis
merci beaucoup fuient rabattables la
sous préfète qui gêne ou tian bonjour je
m'attendais à jouer mais j'espère que ça
voudra lui
bah nous aussi
merci c'est gentil
voilà c'est comme ça on est en direct la
tête ou de nous voir la wii est un
énorme travail fait par upper deck
d'éclat comme ça ça va merci à olivier
mercière à bihorel merci pour vos
analyses la pertinence de rosa la vie
depuis
si votre vote toujours aussi bon
j'essaye ses textes et fils de la
nourrice pour son accueil
on remercie bien surtout des manque de
spectacle géraldine un spécial dédicace
à géraldine tirage et zèle dans les
regarder chloé sophie claire morel
yakine pred julien elodie et bien sûr
vous qu'à relier en remercie tout le
monde bat laon et merci orange vous
rappelle quand même
le prochain rendez vous attendez
mesdames et messieurs il ya un match
d'improvisation intergénérationnel avec
des petits qui vont gérer des moyens et
des grands
et puis c'est un match à ne pas rater le
29 juin à 20 heures vendredi 25 juin à
20 heures à l'école de musique et de
danse de frappe donc vous y serez aussi
serré je serais même coach voilà plus
d'informations sur le paysou cette étude
a donc attaqué des fidèles dans votre
moteur de recherche facebook ou
également retrouver cette captation sur
le site des titans tv.com s'est dit
evelyne s'étaient dit oui oui ça change
et noir comme merci également à toute
l'équipe type de tv sur son 18e
nous avoir en soirée trois sets à les
maintenir à bonne soirée à l'année
prochaine
à l'année prochaine
vous
première année première fois que vous
faites de l'improvisation vous avez
commencé en octobre et la première année
vous remporter la victoire
racontez moi comment ça s'est passé m'a
comme tout le monde feint on a gagné
puisque à petit toujours avec les
partenaires voilà ça s'appelle un manque
d'écouté ça on apprend donc voila comme
comme tout les impros sauf que ben
écoutez le public a décidé que ça que
c'était nous alors m'a écouté voilà
c'était super un moment de partage avec
tout le monde avec avec leur guide comme
avec les autres qu'on a affrontée enfin
qu'on a on a joué avec eux plutôt est
vraiment ben merci cc on n'arrive pas à
y croire première année on gagne la
première fois du coup bah c'est super et
je sais pas comment expliquer
l'enthousiasmé c'est génial qu'est ce
qui était difficile pour cette première
la sq avait des choses qui y vont un peu
déstabilisé parce qu'ils avaient
beaucoup de monde
honnêtement rien je veux dire le public
parce que moi je le voyais pas en tout
cas fin il n'était pas là le public
était absent on était totalement dans
l'impro il y avait plus de public on
était avec les joueurs dans notre
histoire
on était vraiment 100% de notre histoire
donc le public
voilà vous à les emmener le trophée ou
maintenant vous nous le montrer le
trophée vous allez le maître au collège
fal amarres au sol sûrement madame
chiron va l'exposer quelque part moi je
veux le volet pour le métier moi et puis
évidemment vous avez un petit cri de
guerre attention 3 2 1
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bravo le connaissent de la barre au sol
de coignières deuxième on peut dire ça
s'est joué à un petit cheveu
ah oui c'était très serré mon s'est même
amusé c'était super bien pas été mais
cette finale
ouais c'était grave cool parce que déjà
je m'attendais pas qu'on aille en finale
fin on était comme des rats qui était
fort donc l'année dernière vous étiez
quatrième la géo c'était ne vous êtes
deuxièmes l'année prochaine c'est quoi
bah on vise le premier un petit mot du
lion sur ton équipe
non très fier de bad et 6 qui ont joué
là mais ils étaient 13 ans tous dans le
dans l'atelier et donc du coup très
faire des 13 on a passé une très bonne
année ensemble est très contents de ce
qu'ils ont fait soit de ce qu'ils ont
produit
c'est très plaisant et c'est un bonheur
vraiment travailler avec bercy
allez merci entend il raconte nous un
peu cette finale et puis dit nous aussi
comment tu travailles tout au long de
l'année avec les collégiennes et
collégiens
surtout que c'est leur première année là
ouais alors j'ai commencé par le début
donc en fait là où c'est intéressant
pour moi c'est quand tu arrives dans un
collège où tu dois tout créer une équipe
un collectif
on a eu un peu de mal à trouver des
garçons on a notre deux seuls
représentants de garçons dans cette
équipe des prêts mais non j'ai bien
apprécié les une belle infrastructure
une vraie salle théâtre donc ça c'est
plutôt cool et j'ai bien aimé la
découvrir donc on va commencer par les
bases vraiment on a vraiment des jeunes
qui ne connaissent absolument pas
l'impro pour certains qui ont déjà fait
du théâtre je crois mais ça s'arrête là
et pour la finale non c'était plutôt
cool on sait surtout marre et le reste
bon ça c'est le jeu qui fait ça le
public me voit voit le match nous on
voit juste le spectacle et le fait de
s'amuser et je crois qu'ils se sont bien
amusés vu comment ils ont chaud amusé
ouais c'est bien mu et ouais
qu'est ce qui t'a plu ce soir tout pas
si qu'est ce que tu penses avoir rappelé
pas on n'a pas été en finale mais c'est
pas grave
enfin oui on est dans la 1ère demi on a
perdu les demi finales 6 ha bah c'était
bien de pioncer un musée je pense que
c'est le principal
c'est de tout de tout péter
et toi ce que tu peux nous dire ce que
tu as pensé de cette finale toi
personnellement et puis avec ton équipe
bah que c'était bien c'était qu'on s'est
bien éclatés que va on est une bonne
équipe
je pense qu on vous reverra l'année
prochaine j'espère way attend on sera là
l'année prochaine
ok merci donc n'aura lieu qu'il ya
quelque chose qui m'a marqué déjà dans
cette soirée
tu es beaucoup intervenu je suis
beaucoup intervenu sur les deux premiers
matches sur les matches de qualification
mais après ils se mettent une pression
énorme ses enfants ils voient qu'il ya
du monde
ils aideront pas l'habitude de jouer
dans ces conditions c'est des conditions
qui impressionne et du coup j'ai envie
de bien faire parce qu'ils savent qu'il
ya quand même beaucoup d'enjeu tout cas
ils y mettent beaucoup d'enjeu et c'est
vrai que du coup des fois ça les fait
déjouer je suis beaucoup intervenu parce
que effectivement ils ont ils ont ils
ont fait quelques quelques ratés de
confusion de manque d'écouté ça nuit à
la compréhension du public donc je suis
bien obligé d'intervenir
c'est le rôle de l'arbitré alors il y
avait beaucoup de nouveaux cette année
et c'est une équipe qui a commencé à
l'improvisation au mois d'octobre
dernier le collège la mare e sole qui a
remporté le championnat
qu'est ce qu'on pense de tout ça alors
c'est pas finalement les équipes peut
retrouver d'habitude c'est pas les
équipes qu'on retrouvait d'habitude
parce que c'est aussi sait aussi que les
groupes change des enfants change les
établissements aussi mais la culture
d'impro s'installe aujourd'hui dans
d'autres établissements et le ce qui est
chouette avec le collège de la mare au
sol mais comme les prêts qu'ils étaient
là aussi
et qui en sont à leur première
participation c'est que
vienne la avec juste la folie du jeu est
en fait du coup ils sont complètement
détachée de l'enjeu est en fait c'est et
c'est ça qui a fait la différence c'est
à dire que ils sont pas mis de pression
ils ont contredit l'ont fait les ils ont
fait ce qu'ils savaient faire ce qu'ils
faisaient de bien et comme ils l'ont
fait depuis le début de l'année et ça a
marché pour eux et tant mieux pour eux
ces décès les bovins clair je pense
c'était le 19 ème site mythe toi tu es
là depuis le premier on le verra au
prochain
jusqu'à quand ouais mais depuis le
premier cycle mi temps tant
qu'organisateur mais on peut dire aussi
que j'étais là à trappes à l'époque des
championnats intercollèges en 1991 et
que j'avais foulée ou aussi comme ses
enfants mais je suis là juste que quand
je sais pas jusqu'à quand mais en tout
cas le cycle mythe a bon dos et je pense
qu'on peut lui souhaiter bonne longue
vie devant toi on te souhaite longue vie
merci orliac in alors président des ja
la 19e édition du cycle mythe
on vous voit monter sur la patinoire
tout à l'heure vous êtes toujours le
sourire alors comment s'est passée cette
soirée va bien bien évidemment je suis
extrêmement heureux de voir ce qui se
passe on a une grosse énergie
véritablement dans les collèges et ça
c'est vraiment très très intéressant et
au delà de cette énergie à de la
créativité de l'imaginaire un peu
découle de temps en temps pas toujours
peut-être que là il en faudrait un peu
plus pour aujourd'hui mais mais quand
même globalement je trouve qu'il ya un
bel enthousiasme c'est bien alors à
noter il y avait beaucoup de nouveaux
cette cette année mais ça c'est pas
forcément ressenti de dans le jeu
c'était c'était une belle soirée
oui la preuve quand on voit le résultat
c'est pas les équipes les plus habitués
qui finalement gagné donc ça c'est
plutôt assez encourageant qu'est ce qui
se prépare pour l'année prochaine y aura
un peu plus de deux collèges encore qui
vont arriver un ou deux peut-être je
crois que c'est engager les contacts
sont en cours
effectivement l'idée c'est de rayonner
sur l'ensemble de la communauté d'agglo
non je crois qu'on va bientôt couvrir
l'ensemble de notre territoire alors une
dernière question c'est un travail qui
se fait sur toute l'année on commence en
octobre il ya plusieurs phases
successives qui se font et puis après on
arrive à cette phase finale
oui c'est l'occasion pour saluer une
nouvelle fois les équipes enseignants
d'une part et les équipes de déclic
théâtre qu'ils fournissent et un travail
c'est donc assez important et justement
ça permet à ces deux milieux finalement
qui sont un peu éloignés de pouvoir se
rencontrer
rendez vous l'année prochaine absolument
avec enthousiasme
[Musique]
le soleil est arrivé cet enfant
réchauffer la chaleur et tous les ans et
j'ai envie de dire ouais il fait beau